Luxor is a busy port for river cruise boats.
Fleets of these provide multiday Nile cruises,...
...which have become a standard part of an Egyptian tour.
We're riding one farther upstream for a look at the most scenic stretch of the Nile.
As if on a floating resort hotel, tourists enjoy the deck...
...with its pool, the attentive service...
...and the views from their perch atop three floors of staterooms.
The trip upriver takes you by natural beauty...
...and seemingly ancient scenes interrupted only by modern cruise boats.
Long stretches pass by timeless slices of Egyptian life...
...as vacationers have little option but to relax...
...and live at the pace of the steady boat...
...heading against the current of the fabled river.
It's so peaceful, until the tranquility is broken by pirates?
Nope! They're eager and enterprising salesmen...
...who artfully tie up to the surging river boats to display, model and haggle,...
...selling their souvenirs the hard way.